[Musique]
bonjour guillex bonjour merci de venir
jusqu'à nous vous venez nous raconter
nos narrer un certain nombre d'aventures
que vous comptez dans ce livre peut-être
même deux d'abord déjà celui-là l'océan
me dit reviens 180 jours à l'assaut de
l'Atlantique le même texte en version un
petit peu plus animée avec des dessins
pour vous présenter rapidement vous avez
30 ans vous êtes aventuriers navigateur
tour du monde par l'épaule et vous avez
traversé l'Atlantique à la RAM dans les
deux sens 181 jours question pour
commencer pourquoi est-ce que vous
faites tout ça pourquoi bah écoutez
parce que c'est quelque chose qui me
plaît qui me tient à cœur et en effet
depuis l'âge de 18 ans en fait je pars
un petit peu à l'aventure et je me
voyais pas trop travailler voilà dans un
bureau assis sur une chaise j'ai besoin
d'être en extérieur de sentir les
éléments et c'est ce qui me plaît c'est
pour ça que de le faire vous dites
souffrir de la bougie
justement d'où est-ce que cela vous
vient cette envie de voyager de bouger
tout le temps bah écoutez alors moi j'ai
eu la chance de grandir sur une petite
île en Bretagne donc on était la seule
maison à 7 ans j'ai eu mon premier
bateau même avant je partais seul en mer
j'ai toujours eu cette liberté en fait
et cette soif un petit peu d'aventure et
en fait j'avais qu'un rêve depuis
toujours c'était d'acheter un bateau et
de partir traverser les océans regarder
de l'autre côté de l'horizon et dès
l'âge de 18 ans je suis parti voilà en
Australie sans rien je dormais dans la
rue je parlais pas un mot anglais et
voilà petit à petit j'ai enchaîné des
boulots j'ai pu gagner un petit peu
d'argent pour concrétiser ce rêve qui
était d'acheter ce fameux voilier et à
20 ans je suis parti tout ça au départ
divinec petit île bretonne c'est
exactement ce qu'on prenne bien direct
le livre démarre assez fort romane c'est
le nom de votre bateau se retourne vous
êtes à califonction dessus et autour
océan et vous repassez un petit peu le
film de toute la situation dangereuse
dans laquelle vous avez pu vous trouver
est-ce que ce jour-là vous dites que
vous voyez la main en face à ce
moment-là ouais en fait donc j'ai fait
cette première traversée Canaries
Caraïbes en 74 jours et c'était une
chouette aventure mais c'est vrai que je
suis resté un petit peu sur ma faim en
disant bon c'était bien mais il manquait
quelque chose et c'est pour ça que j'ai
voulu faire ce retour États-Unis
Bretagne en fait la même route tu gères
à David il y a plus de 40 ans et là
c'est vrai que j'ai été servi vraiment
voilà peut-être un petit peu trop et en
effet il y a un moment je me suis
retrouvé à l'envers retourné avec mon
bateau parce que je me suis pris une
tempête tropicale et là à ce moment là
j'étais enfermé dans le bateau sans air
avec de l'eau qui rentrait donc déjà là
je me suis dit c'est là c'est compliqué
là il faut vite sortir là parce que
sinon ça va pas le faire et j'ai réussi
à me dégager du bateau et en effet donc
j'étais sur sur un califourchon à
l'envers sur la coque de mon bateau en
train de me tenir avec un bout avec les
vagues qui déferlait impossible de
redresser le ballon et tout ça vous le
racontez dans un style assez truculent y
soudé est-ce que la peinture dans ce
cercueil marin vu qu'il y a pas d'autres
mots
ses promesses les a tenues les a tenues
ouais ouais comme il fallait là
d'ailleurs j'ai j'ai fait mon plein
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui le bateau à
vendre ça peut intéresser quelqu'un mais
oui en effet c'est vrai que bah voilà
entre ce retournement cette perte de
communication avec la terre ferme ce
manque de nourriture j'ai perdu 14 kg le
fait de ne plus pouvoir transformer
l'eau salée en eau douce à part
manuellement la nourriture moisie les
toutes l'humidité pas de feu pendant la
nuit aucun moyen de détecter la plupart
du temps par les bateaux bon bah là on
se demande comment on va faire pour
arriver l'autre côté quoi vraiment c'est
challenge sur challenge en permanence
quoi mais dans tout cela il y a quand
même des belles rencontres direction des
justement est-ce qu'il y en a une qui
vous a touché assez enfin parmi toutes
celles que vous avez pu faire est-ce
qu'il y en a une pizza le plus touché
bah oui oui il y a des rencontres qui
montent sur des faits donc moi en fait
ma première aventure c'est un tour du
monde à la voile avec une fameuse poule
Monique donc j'ai un je vais vous
demander de sa nouvelle tout à l'heure
mais déjà c'est donc j'ai un lien
particulier avec les animaux vraiment et
en Bretagne j'aime beaucoup pêcher et
c'est vrai que pendant cette traversée
bon bah voilà on est seul seul surtout
qu'on a plus de moyens de communication
et en fait donc j'avais des poissons qui
pouvaient me suivre dont des dorades il
y a une dorade que j'ai entre guillemets
apprivoisé que j'ai nommé Paulette et
qui m'a suivi pendant des semaines et
logiquement j'aurais dû attraper pour la
manger parce que j'avais faim mais non
en fait je me suis lié d'amitié avec
Paulette et elle était là à côté de mon
bateau elle me suivait je lui parlait
moi elle me répondait pas forcément mais
il y a quelque chose qui s'est passé
elle ne pouvait pas répondre
effectivement il reste des encore plus
sérieusement on ne peut évoquer l'océan
sans évoquer la question des déchets on
avait vu un certain nombre d'échés
plastiques qu'est-ce que vous avez vu
justement dans le détail et puis aussi
évidemment qu'est-ce que vous en tant
que navigateur vous faites pour protéger
l'océan ouais ben écoutez moi je suis je
suis témoin de vraiment de ce que je
vois donc j'essaie de le partager mais
bah j'apprends pas grand chose de
nouveau si vous voulez mais c'est vrai
que bah j'étais confronté en permanence
à la pollution plastique
je pouvais voir un sac plastique un
bidon un ballon de baudruche on y pense
pas ça les petits ballons pour les
enfants mais quand lâche il part loin et
puis un moment bah il va il va arrêter
quelque part et souvent dans l'océan
j'ai vu des animaux comme des fous de
bassans avec des filets de pêche autour
de la pâte donc voilà quand tu vois ça
enfin ça fait ça fait vraiment mal et
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps dans les
glaces au Groenland en Antarctique et
c'est vrai que bah voilà la fonte elle
est bien elle est bien présente et ça va
pas ça va pas en s'améliorant comme et
je pense que voilà les gens sont
courantes ce qui se passe et voilà on
essaye tous de faire quelque chose pour
améliorer tout ça direct ce dès l'océan
me dit reviens 180 un jour à la sœur de
l'Atlantique il y a une question que
vous posez au 150 au 56e jour de votre
voyage qu'est-ce qu'être aventurier en
2022 maintenant qu'il n'y a plus de
terre à découvrir que toutes les cartes
ont été établies je vous pose la
question bah qu'est-ce qui était
aventure c'est pas forcément aller à
l'autre bout du monde comme je peux
faire elle se met en situation parfois
très risqué mais voilà c'est de se
dépasser en fait c'est ça l'idée et
voilà ce procurer des challenges en
permanence un aventurier ça peut être
monté sa société c'est c'est
possiblement avoir une vie de famille
aussi en fait voilà on est tous amené à
être confrontés à
des challenges et on est là pour se
battre et pour faire en sorte que que ça
se passe bien vous c'est d'Atlantique
vous ramenez je dois l'océan doit
l'océan lorsqu'on comprenne bien et tout
cela quand même à un coup comment est-ce
que tous ces projets sont financés c'est
financés par des partenaires par des
projets comme ces livres par exemple des
films aussi là en ce moment par exemple
je prépare la la Route du Rhum avec un
objectif de Vendée Globe donc là je suis
un gros bateau mon bateau s'appelle
freelance.com d'où voilà c'est le nom de
mon sponsor et voilà comment ces
aventures peuvent être financées
justement la Route du Rhum que vous
préparez est-ce que vous êtes prêt et
ben ouais moi je suis prêt je suis super
motivé après c'est vrai que là je change
complètement de programme voilà je passe
d'un rameur avec 1,5 m² de d'habitacle
un bateau qui avançait à peine un nœud
là il y a encore quelques jours je
faisais des pointes à 27 noeuds avec mon
voilier bateau 18 mètres avec un mode 30
mètres qui de 4 mètres 50 donc ça n'a
rien à voir après voilà ça reste sur la
mer moi c'est ce qui me plaît c'est vrai
que c'est vraiment fantastique je me
sens vraiment privilégié d'avoir la
chance de pouvoir naviguer sur un tel
engin c'est un peu une formule 1 des
mers et c'est vrai que bah voilà c'est
tout ça
vous en avez pas non sur ce bateau non
c'est un bateau dérive ancienne
génération en fait de 2007 mais c'est un
bateau costaud et voilà qui en a quand
même sous le capot départ le 6 novembre
prochain de Saint-Malo direct sur des
vous avez récemment été décoré par le
Semon ship of the Year c'était pas à
Londres alors au-delà bien entendu de la
satisfaction personnelle j'imagine quel
a été le un message envoyé selon vous
avec cette récompense cette récompense
le message de la part des anglais
alors je pourrais pas vous dire
exactement mais c'est surtout par
rapport à ce que vous l'avez pris du
coup je l'ai pris j'étais voilà très
touché très ému c'est que voilà c'est si
j'avais déjà une décoration à peu près
similaire aux États-Unis c'est que je
comprends pas vraiment pourquoi ça m'est
adressé mais c'est vrai qu'après avec le
recul qu'on pense à tout ce que j'ai pu
affronter pendant pendant mes aventures
et c'est vrai qu'il y avait de quoi être
découragé il y avait de quoi
malheureusement que ça se termine mal et
moi j'ai jamais voulu rien lâcher je me
suis battu jusqu'au bout et donc c'est
voilà je pense une preuve aussi de
détermination et de la prochaine
question qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez
qu'on retienne de vous en tant que
navigateur moi j'ai pas envie qu'on
retienne spécialement quelque chose de
moi j'ai voilà je pense juste qu'il faut
vivre à fond en fait voilà il faut pas
il faut pas avoir de regret il faut pas
se poser trop de questions parce que
malheureusement bah voilà la vie passe
vite ça on est au courant mais
malheureusement elle peut passer très
vite dans le sens où elle peut s'arrêter
du jour au lendemain et voilà pour moi
chaque seconde est importante qu'est-ce
que vous dites justement
réponse est peut-être dans la question
mais j'appose quand même à ceux qui
oseraient prendre la mer mais qui
n'osent pas comme vous ben moi je dis
qui ose gagne en fait vraiment en fait
on n'est jamais prêt pour n'importe quel
aventure n'importe quel projet je ne
sais pas possible d'être prêt à 100% en
fait ça existe pas mais il y a un moment
bah voilà il faut se lancer il faut y
aller en fait et potentiellement
peut-être ça marchera pas peut-être ça
nous plaira pas mais au moins on aura
pas de on n'aura pas de déception
vraiment quoi dans l'océan me dit
reviens il y a ce projet dont vous dites
page 28 direction des je pose aussi un
truc que personne n'a encore réussi et
donc je ne peux pas trop le révéler
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est marqué je peux
pas trop le rêver maintenant que vous
êtes là je vais tout savoir je peux pas
je peux pas tout répondre à toutes vos
questions parce qu'en fait j'ai
tellement de projets c'est voilà c'est
mon problème c'est que j'ai un projet la
minute donc j'essaye un peu de de me
concentrer sur le moment présent mais là
déjà bon la route forum le 6 novembre à
bord de mon super voilier quand même
donc ça c'est une aventure à suivre je
pense et puis dans l'objectif de faire
le fameux Vendée Globe tour du monde
voilà le tour dans l’interactique par
les trois pôles sans assistance en total
autonomie quoi et ça ça va être un sacré
challenge je note que vous n'avez pas
voulu répondre à la question alors allez
comme promis une petite question quand
même sur Monique qu'est-ce qu'elle
devient déjà pour ceux qui ne savent pas
oui qui est Monique qui est Monique
alors Monique c'est ma coéquipière en
fait et ben voilà ça c'est la couverture
d'un premier livre lui c'est flammarion
et en fait on a fait un tour du monde
avec Monique par les deux pôles
c'est-à-dire qu'on est on est parti de
Bretagne on a traversé Atlantique
jusqu'au Caraïbes on est parti au
Groenland on a hiverné 130 jours
c'est une poule une poule à une poule à
plumes à une belle rousse qui vient des
des Canaries et une noix une sacrée une
sacrée aventurière en fait vraiment
qu'elle a la patte marine on peut le
dire et Monique voilà n'a peur de rien
elle est à la retraite là-dedans et elle
a la retraite ouais malheureusement
voilà elle est pour l'instant elle elle
profite
et elle est en Bretagne et elle se la
coule douce on peut le dire dernière
question que devient romane romane alors
donc mon rameur je l'ai toujours il est
chez moi aussi en Bretagne il va voilà
il va bien elle va bien plutôt et
malheureusement c'est pas forcément un
bateau que je vais pouvoir regarder même
si j'aurais aimé ce qu'on peut pas voilà
on peut pas tout garder c'est pas
possible et j'espère que voilà ça pourra
servir à une autre personne avec
d'autres projets qu'est-ce qu'il faut
vous souhaiter avant qu'on se quitte et
ben écoutez bon vent
excellent merci beaucoup merci à vous
accéder d'être venu jusqu'à nos l'océan
me dit reviens 180 jours à la salle de
l'Atlantique et également ce texte mon
journal de bord que vous êtes venus nous
présenter merci beaucoup merci à vous
merci c'était l'invité de Paris direct